i am feeling the holiday vibes in the
wall
and lee harris put this outfit on and i
literally was like i look like a
christmas tree like i have
a green bottom and a red top and then he
likes to put this belt on me i'm like
am i liz taylor and cleopatra or is this
a
belt
but i i said okay let's wear it
it feels festive and that's what the
holidays are all about
just having the chance to express
yourself an excuse
to express yourself and um it tis
the season and you know what that means
it means
lots of thoughts and feelings i mean
i think i've been feeling a little
crazy since you know the onset of
thanksgiving halloween i was like
express and it's so awesome and cool and
then thanksgiving came and i was like
[Laughter]
it's the holidays it's just a hard time
this year you know
there are all the feelings involved and
it's a weird holiday season and
hopefully it will be
one year hope i think is on the way and
around the corner and
in some ways that's a great reason to
almost
embrace this even more and not act like
this is forever
i do believe this is temporary i talk to
my kids about it all the time
i also think it's a time we should take
advantage of to do things a little
differently
since we are forced into this what
could we do that will make this a very
memorable time like remember the year we
had to do it this way
so i always like turning a difficult
into a positive
and um i also love talking to you guys
and doing something that we call
drew and a because we put my name with
everything
so does anyone have a holiday related
question
let's see here oh uh bianca hi
um oh my gosh that is so cute
in fact i'm like where are my dogs
though they're
they're traipsing around the building
somewhere who is that
this is bourdain he's a cavalier king
charles spaniel he is seven months old
oh he's so cute oh he's young seven
months
still very much a puppy well um
sorry i keep going on and on about your
doggy
may ask what your question is bianca
yeah
so um you know holidays are going to be
a little different this year my
husband's deployed
i live super close to my in-laws and
they've done you know so much for the
family
and with my husband not being here i'm
the one in charge of gifts i'm just
wondering
what would be something special to get
them this year
okay well my immediate thought is
something personalized
always something they cannot buy in a
store
i think since you're trying to be the
glue of the family
maybe keeping it about the family
rather than something that doesn't
really have to do with the family and
just feels like a gift
so i want to give this some thought but
whatever it's going to be i'm going to
say
pictures engraving like
something that's really about
how to make your in-laws feel like
they're surrounded
in the family your particular family i
want to make it personal
and i'm going to give you an answer at
the end of the show does that sound good
sounds good also if you don't mind can i
help you do it
okay okay good um i'm like
how do you feel about me getting
personally involved we've actually taken
it upon ourselves to think about
bianca's question
from earlier and we have two ideas one
for me and one from ross bianca
there you are i love you ross i love you
oh my gosh thank you so much look how
cute i know with her little king charles
well we've been thinking very seriously
about what to do for your
relatives for christmas okay i think
that you should get a series of mugs
and the reason why is because it's
usually something that everybody holds
in their hands every day i know i do
case in point literally literally so
i would like you to select four special
family photographs that includes
everybody so that your
in-laws can actually feel it hold it and
look at it every single day
i love that and uh something that my
mom's best friend did for me
before my mom passed away she got all of
her recipes
and printed them out and made a little
cookbook with like my mom's recipes and
bananas
so i have that those treasured recipes
forever and ever and ever
it's one of a kind ross that is such
a good idea i treasure it so
what do you think bianca i think that's
a great idea especially with my husband
being deployed
and not here i think that would be like
meaning everything to them
so okay great so we're gonna send you a
500
gift card just to get it all done get
right on top of it
it's on us and please
extend our very best to your
very brave and wonderful husband who's
often deployed and
bianca your in-laws no matter what you
give them
what a lucky set of parents they are to
have a daughter-in-law like you
yeah thank you and everyone
else and our vff's thank you for
bringing the spirit today
and to anyone watching at home thank you
for joining
ross and i we wish you a wonderful rest
of your day
take this with you thank you everybody
you